we have here an emulator for the
Cambridge EDSAC it is a lot more
user-friendly on this screen than it
would have been initially when remember
you are dealing with five hold paper
tape that's what you program wenting on
your answers came back out on five hold
paper tape which was your job to put
through a teleprinter machine which
chattered away read your tape and
printed out the answers fortunately we
have the printed out answers shown in
front of us here is the standard display
of this emulator so handily written by
our friend Martin Campbell Kelly from
the University of Warwick you can
download this for yourself it's free to
use and just play with it to your
heart's content
and it's very nice to have the
opportunity to play with a really
genuine early first generation computer
we've been talking about John von
Neumann or Johnny von Neumann call me
Johnny yeah it's a keys being built in
Cambridge but how does it end up getting
connected to von Neumann is that what
we're going yes that's right it's it's
the other way around of course that the
the person who built EDSAC maurice
wilkes exact contemporary Alan Turing
both got first class degrees in
mathematics
he was alone Morris Wilkes who went to
John Von Neumanns summer school in 1946
at the University of Pennsylvania the
Moore School of Engineering
Paula Morris has such difficulties with
raising the money with getting his
passport straight and all sorts of other
issues that he actually arrived four
weeks late for a six-week course one has
to remember of course in those days it
was not straightforward you were talking
about ships you know billing via Iceland
and heaven knows where and train
journeys to finish off down to
Pennsylvania but anyway I think he must
have had what was the technology roneoed
or cyclists styled and notes when he got
there he got copies of the notes and was
able to follow exactly what was going on
learnt about the von night at the
propose of on Norman architecture knew
that there was going to be this thing
called edvac been built in pennsylvania
and he and all the other participants or
less I think invited to go off do your
own thing
support the cause of general purpose
binary based digital computers all
electronic not electromechanical for the
inner electronics and in fact it's worth
saying something about this whole
business about what did it cost you to
be all electronic in those days I would
remind you that Tommy flowers decision
with max human to build Colossus out of
thermionic valve that's vacuum tubes for
those of you still in North America it
did cost you yes you could switch mono
switch them off you could use them as
logic elements but boy did they consume
electricity and and then of course you
have to have air conditioning to get rid
of the heat that they've produced all
the time what hell things that was you
you wanted to use them as switching
elements but you really paid the price
in terms of power consumption so Tommy
flowers and his special purpose Colossus
machine six kilowatts head sat now being
rebuilt in Cambridge the EDSAC rebuild
should go live this coming summer 2018
watch out for that good time to visit
the National Museum of computing which
is co located on the Bletchley Park site
how a consumption of edsac 11 kilowatts
for comparison power consumption of
ENIAC the gun a retractor is
special-purpose computer 1946 University
of Pennsylvania USA I bet you can't
remember the number Sean it's horrifying
20 150 kilowatts all of that using
thermionic valves for the logic elements
inside your computer yes that could
certainly be done the big problem was
memory
there was really no obvious technology
for memory you get round it on the
Colossus machine by saying well your
data which you want to remember just
cycles around on a continuous loop
the program well that's easy that's not
on tape because that is it's so such a
special purpose machine you key in the
program on switches unit selectors so
your memory therefore your data was
paper tape but if you didn't want paper
tape whizzing round at 30 miles an hour
what other options were available to you
and the answer is not many and as we'll
find out on Ed sack with Morris Wilkes
coming out of a radar background he knew
that in the early days of radar when
pulses came along and these are
interesting pulses could it be an
approaching German bomber you wanted to
not only get hold of the pulse but to
hang on to it and remember it so you
could have analyzed its shape and so on
and the way they did that is the most
amazing technology it's called mercury
delay lines the bleep pulse that you get
was put basically through a little
loudspeaker so it went bleep but instead
of transmitting through air so you could
hear it it was transmitted down a column
of mercury why because sound travels a
lot slower in mercury than it does in
air and at the other end there was a
microphone at the other end of your tube
which heard the bleep and displayed it
on an oscilloscope screen for you but
then recycled it it took it back to the
start of the mercury tube and sent it
down again so you had a continuously
circulating system that showed you what
your pulses were and the idea was to use
that same technology to represent the
zeros and ones in computer memory which
they did it was not very satisfactory in
so many ways but you just had to do your
best
presumably deteriorate it didn't let the
sound or no because when you when you
detected it at the other end you
amplified it before you fed it back
again so you could keep the purity of
the pulse going for as long as you
wanted to that was the idea so the story
continues maurice wilkes came back to
england and in a testament really to
Cambridge's being fairly well healed
and to their faith in morris
there need to be at the forefront of all
this stuff they buy they I mean the
University and the mathematics
department at Cambridge agreed to
bankroll Morris to build one of these
newfangled machines provided that when
it was completed it could offer a
service to the University this is very
different to what happened in most of
the universities where electronics
engineers were just allowed to build
systems where you just played with them
and didn't really offer a computing
service the community at all they were
just pure research machines Morris found
himself a very good hardware engineer
called Bill Rennick
who was just excellent you had to have
this you had to have a real devoted
electronics engineer who knew what they
were doing to get all of this working
when you look at it you've got this box
it's hard way you've got to get it
working you've got to get instructions
in it you've got to make it work but you
need a software person and you need the
world's first ever system software
person and they'd better be good somehow
these people seem to come along as and
when they're needed I've never
understand quite why and the answer at
Cambridge was a really talented person
who I didn't know but rather slightly
called David David wheeler we can now
say that as part of the celebrations
this summer when the EDSAC rebuild is
switched on or works perfectly to go
along with that a very good friend of
ours on computer file professor Martin
Campbell Kelly developed an emulation of
edsac and how it works so rather than
talking in abstract about Ed's act let's
get stuck in and run some programs on
Ed's I can see what you're up against
with a very genuine first generation
machine where you will program in the
crudest
and most brain damaging form of
assembler you can imagine and you've got
to get it right it is not easy to debug
edsac programs it can be done but you
know it's hard stuff you want to be a
pioneer this is what you get I think
what I'll do is first of all just for
fun
run some programs and get the feeling
for how nice it is to mess about even on
a very early machine like that for those
of you interested afterwards what is a
great computer science technical
interest is how on earth do you boot
this thing up so it can read in your
program in other words it's not going to
BIOS it's far too early for that but
what was the equivalent of the BIOS what
was it that got you started that you
have to have there even to be able to
read in a paper - well that's called
initial orders we'll do those later for
the moment we'll just accept that
initial orders version 2 is the one that
is relevant here and I've used initial
orders to load in a program that was
written by an early pioneer called Sandy
Douglas here's his name hey as Douglas
if I load in that program now by start
here and this really is outset but this
was an oscilloscope screen this is the
so called display of the long tank with
a long tank of mercury which held
roughly a killer word 1024 18 bit memory
words were held in mercury so it's like
1k words to get a few K bytes that was
your limit okay so one you got used to
reading these oscilloscope screens and
remember this oscilloscope screen is not
the memory itself it's peeping at the
memory by having a little monitor as it
were checking the pulses in the mercury
tank and displaying them on the
oscilloscope and remember and give
thanks for the fact that this loading
please wait
headset user first dial now comes back
at you courtesy of Martin in a clearly
visible screen in the good old days
you've probably come back to you on
paper tape or something and you would
have to go and print it off to get your
results but this is pretty well
interactive on this dial here on the
console do we want the headset to go
first we user to go first well the game
we're playing here is one known in the
US notes whereas tic-tac-toe
known in the UK as noughts and crosses
but simple I think everybody knows the
rules and I think everybody pretty well
knows that if you play optimally it's
always a draw I have a feeling there's a
number file on it somewhere there must
be a number father on it somewhere yes
you can always force a draw so should we
do first of all we'll take the lead and
force a draw so EDSAC or user first well
we'll say user first so I dial one
now let's what see what happens
oh look at that the cathode ray tube
display has been altered to by the
program to actually show the grid that
we're going to play tic-tac-toe on and
because it's me the user first it's now
saying to me died on my move now here's
the key of the top lock nine eight seven
six five four three two one those are
the areas on the tic-tac-toe board and
as we all know I think optimal strategy
is to grab the center one first of all
yeah and then Sachs responded by putting
a nought in at the top left I'm going to
respond by knowing it's among them to
dial in seven now I should you think
that's a slow response was that really
that slow that is six times faster than
edsac was I've calibrated it this
emulator on this machine seems terribly
slow but it's running six times faster
than that site did right at the very end
I may allow myself if you want to be
shocked and horrified to click the thing
up here that says real time that will
slow it down so that it really is as
slow as the edge so why don't we do that
now let's do that now after you make
your move let's see how slowly there
have been one of those does that looks
like an old telephone which is no
telephone and I think that was there for
diagnostic purposes on the actual lid so
I guess we're trying to win this our way
out
906 isn't it I put an X in there
otherwise so the wretched machines gonna
win was that slower I think it was but
look it's blocked me there it's doing
the right thing so I put in an X
at eight there we go
it's definitely slower definitely slower
and good old Sandy's program has already
told me it's a drawing game so let's
load up from the library ah
Conway okay well I think we all know
about Conway's Game of Life there are
these sets of dots and there are various
rules about two got in the middle either
been overcrowded with too many dots
around it or getting all lonely and out
on a limb and dying off but in the
middle if it's just got the right number
of friends then they breed and they
spawn off more things was a very popular
invention by John Connell in it was it
the 70s or the eight is somewhere around
there and everybody was playing life
using pencil paper methods or using
computers lastly of course now this was
not written actually at the time of Ed
sacks unveiling at 49 I've had invented
but somebody later later on with this
simulator in in mind and in view has
actually written Conway's life to
display here for us so letters load this
thing in is by n Gillman written in 1998
and the rule is on this emulator for
those of you that downloaded the program
you are displaying is the one that will
get loaded and run when you press start
so just keep your program windows in the
correct order one on top of another and
the one at the top is the one that will
load so we'll load it up with start
takes quite a while to load things it's
quite a complicated program ah now it
started calculating now this is the
initial configuration it warns you here
each generation takes about five exact
minutes now I have not put it onto real
edsac slow time I've put it on six times
faster simulator time again all
according to Conway's rules it will look
it's gone it's changed new generation so
I think my rule is not right it is
roughly five to six times faster here
because it's taking around about a
minute
I just dent put it onto real time as
well we'd run out of tape we'd run out
of tape but anyway so I can see a clock
on the right that looks like it's going
a bit fast is that I think that's trying
to show you genuine EDSAC time so if on
this simulator it's five or six times
faster than real as that would be it's
therefore making the clock of every six
times faster I think to show you how
many elapsed minutes it would have taken
on edsac down the bottom there I can see
a lot of flickering and flushing that's
all the calculator that's all the
calculation this is showing you see look
you've got a multiplier register in your
CPU you've got the thing you're
multiplying by you've got the answer
which comes out in the accumulator even
modern chips have an accumulator for
your current arithmetic alarm sir right
the SVT here is showing you the address
of the current instruction and the
actual bit pattern for the current
instruction that has been decoded and
executed is shown in the so-called order
tank so that's the instruction register
that's the pointer telling you where
from memory you've taken that
instruction and it's a pretty minimal
sleeper you the thing we notice here is
there are virtually no general-purpose
registers which is what you're given a
modern CPU so I think that's a pretty
good one actually to illustrate with we
can stop it off now so I hope this is
convinced a fair number of you
particularly those of you very keen on
history of computing and low-level
programming in general that it's a
testament really to the very Spartan
architecture of edsac you know cut
everything down to the bare minimum get
it working it's got to give a service
and that means that it stood the test of
time it's worth rebuilding people could
finally ease relatively easy to do a
good emulator for it and that in a sense
has made it worthwhile to rebuild at
Bletchley Park so you can be part of
this get hold of Martin's emulator enjoy
yourself right
ultra low level programs for
for insects oh and remember when you're
doing is that the actual pseudo tape you
type up in the end
although on these program listings
you're allowed to put comments on
because you're a weak human who needs to
remind yourself of why you're doing that
when you actually key in the tape itself
that backs this up there must be no
comments no extraneous characters only
whitespace is permitted so there you are
anyway enjoy yourselves and the next
video is basically saying how dot earth
do we get this thing to boot that is the
von Neumann architecture and it's very
very similar today there was a big
debate at the time about that store that
memory shouldn't you for safety's sake